wenn ich noch voll in die pedale treten
die kette runter vom ritzel die pedale
drehen durch und ich verlege ich mitten
auf die kreuzungen service kids und
herzlich willkommen zu einer neuen folge
mit macht und warum ist echt ein
marketing-coup den jihad ich bin auch
kohlmarkt 30 einmal kurbad andersrum
gerne wenn ich dich überholt dann war
dann kann nichts ausnehmen verpiss dich
doch einfach ja genau
durch mein system verwirrt geben
ich glaube da kommt eine 2 wo ich kenne
den links eben hin und her wackelt
kräftig table und mach mal ein dia show
und meine dialekt ich hab noch keiner
die allianz habe ich nicht alt aber ich
habe ja ich habe hier warte warte warte
den endstand er nimmt ihn dafür mit
seiner ist natürlich was willst du
wortwahl
entweder haben die plötzlich alle nicht
mehr in diese weise sollte werden ganz
so viele aufhören versuche und alle
kamen in die mitte unserer zu hauen und
hatten damit auch erfolg werden sollen
sechs versuche dj peter leute ich kann
euch meine geschichte erzählen die hab
ich dir noch nicht erzählt max com
wir raten zur arbeit gefahren und ich
habe mich nicht so das frühe aufstehen
gewöhnt deswegen war ich noch ein
bisschen im nebel
nachdem auch unmut vor dem reichstag ihr
wisst was ich meine und dann fahre ich
an so eine kreuzung eine recht große
kreuzung vier spuren ohne halt an neben
mir autos vor mir autos rum mich herum
autos als fahrradfahrer relativ riskant
so dann wird die ampel grünlicht steigt
in die pedale stelle mich auf damit ich
mehr kraft habe also auf die kreuzung
raus hat schon so 10.15 kamera drauf
schneller schneller schneller schneller
schneller
er kommt er kommt daher kommt der name
das gras so wartet die kreuzung ein
auf einmal lag ich so ein knacken
aus der ecke wo sich das hätten die
perle geworfen glaube ich jan hat mitte
dessen der mitte des mitte der rabatte
kann das passieren
ja okay da kam es ihr zurück so zurück
doch ich hab wasser besitzt kann den
lauf runter auf wenig runter so leute
dann verhört und knacken
aus der von der kette sehr schön meinte
wunderbar aber ich wollte es also ein
knacken aus der kette und denke mir nur
so ist es auch wirklich so geben in
diesem zeichentrickfilm und dann als
nächste was passiert wenn ich noch voll
in die pedale trete die kette runter vom
rätsel
die pedale drehen durch und ich lege
mich mitten auf die kreuzungen auch mit
ordentlich tempo so das war heute mein
morgen mein start in den tag und ich
denke bitte hoffentlich überfährt mich
jetzt niemand und hinter mir standen
wirklich 10 20 autos oder so habe ich
angefangen zu gucken
das war aber noch ok aber hier brennt
ein lag haben die die gefahren
wir wollten das aber da war ein polizist
der sagt hey übervater nicht oder land
angefeindet
in mainz ist als ob du jetzt auch nach
passau flirt er rechts von ihr dritter
mann hinter uns kommt auch einer der
auch nur eine ahnung was ich so was hier
immer was passieren ok piste kommt mir
hat der wird natürlich neuer junger baum
hat jeder juli an der angel
die da rechts um auch allen und geier
nur dreck kommt der kommt es auch mal
hinter dich wasser abwasser wird auch
unser wasser was machen was machen wir
jetzt voll eingekesselt alter können wir
uns die können uns aber nicht unter
anderem da drüben oder motivieren selbst
angegriffen kommt greift die anderen
dann können wir fliegen wir können die
anrechnung berlin
und zwar genau jetzt jetzt jetzt kommt
weil du die im auge ich bau weiter weil
du im auge
bei einer richtung cash sehr gut also
leute kommt mir ein alter angefangen
das einzig gute war dass es so früh am
morgen passiert ist da war ich einfach
noch wie gesagt bisschen geistesabwesend
da hat sie nicht so sehr weh getan aber
nicht als in den tag über im büro
irgendwo auf gestand erinnerung gelaufen
ist ziemlich stark aufgefallen weil es
schon extrem weh getan hat
ich habe mir mein knie auf bisschen
blutig geschäften so ist schau mal was
macht auch gold was oft der typ ist
immer noch da lauf läuft er wegläuft
daraus du stehst du ziemlich doof
konstruiere ich komme ich komme kommt
weg direkt aber ich hab ihn hat in
happiness raus es sei denn der pelle
pass kurz auf ok ich muss auf den
anderen schauen jungen
you're just hold me postiert nicht im
allgemeinen muss auch sagen dass dieses
diese büro sitze reim ich richtig fertig
macht ist es überhaupt nicht mein ding
für mich da noch keine konkreten zusagen
acht stunden an einer stelle zu setzen
es kommt einfach so unnatürlich vor
aber okay das ist vielleicht einfach mal
studenten leicht drüber runtergefahren
bist wir binden
ach du brauchst die da oben lang hey
komm und ich tricks die von unten her
was tust du ich bin und ich bin und
nicht benannten kannst du dir
unternommen haben sie gemacht wenn auch
hier und jetzt kommen wir unter aber
leuten darunter ok den gewinn
da kommt noch eine gute chance
nein sicher 3 1 habe ich okay ich habe
die anderen auch hey hey das tat richtig
komisch aus als würde aus mehreren
richtungen kommen aber sind nur 22
gestorben
bleibt nur noch tobi ok meist sehr
schöne runde
was ich bei dir passiert wahrscheinlich
nicht allzu viel in der schule erzählt
aber mit sich ja nicht für youtube kanal
und ansonsten alles ja als ich sagte ja
auch fahrradfahren in der großstadt in
berlin ist richtig riskanten die
autofahren so rücksichtslos
new york barclays ja oder fühlt sich mal
wieder berlin bei planes ist ein echter
die beinahe vollkommen knicken überall
zugestellt von lieferwagen dazu warte
man macht den man nicht so schnell
fertig nur noch mit rüberkommen der ich
laufen schon mal in seine richtung aber
klar betreiben kann der kommt ja bald
holz per drop löschen
ich habe aber kein ich probiere herz zu
locken ja ok macht das macht das kommt
er her aber hast du vielleicht denken
goal.com lockten euro
treten solche dicken dass man auf lenkt
duden ab alter denkt du denn habe ich
versuche irgendeinen appell an ihm
vorbei zu schmeißen
vielleicht wenn ich runter gehen wird
mich so sell herunter
okay ich hatte hier in der kirche alles
was wie die habe ich diese ende perle
vorbei geworfen mein kleiner fixen ich
hab auch nen ich habe auch eine jetzt
fick dich mein junge was habe ich
gemacht wie konnte diese npd vorbei
schmeißen ist durch dieses eine kleine
loch da im baum geflogen oder wie ich
hasse diese ratte verrecken
wir müssen zeit überlegt spielen du fix
sohn einer [ __ ] kann ich irgendwie
schach halten
knapp auf einlagen gold kommt vielleicht
mal an wollte jetzt gibt ja auch unter
wasser ist sehr schön
damit haben wir eine runde geritzt oder
wie und erzählt geschichten den
kommentaren von euren fahrer unfällen
was ich stapelt ab für den winter